on raised ground east of harkeev
russia's 59th tank regiment dug in
watching villages below the tree line
offered little protection they were
comprehensively destroyed but not before
carrying out war crimes say ukrainians
these tanks we join military prosecutors
out gathering evidence against them
russian uh tanks were here and the
village is there
the village is over there yes and you
think the russian tanks attacked the
village
uh yes of course can you catch them can
you punishment do you think i think yes
we in the future we will punch the
punish
you can punish the russians yes
but they're in russia or donbass how do
you catch them
we'll try it we will try
as well as shelling civilian homes from
here the russians are accused of an
attack on civilian vehicles bringing in
aid and food
souvenirs
investigators from ukraine and lithuania
were searching the destroyed russian
positions for evidence
piece by piece the prosecutors are
building a case against the russians
searching for evidence in this tree line
in the wrecked russian armor they've
left behind and the camps they've
deserted but they're then linking that
to what they're finding in the villages
below the wrecked civilian homes the
stories of civilians killed by artillery
strikes because attacking civilians
without military justification is a
clear war crime
today in kiev sergeant vadim shisha
marine became the first russian to be
convicted of a war crime pleading guilty
to shooting an unarmed 62 year old man
dead ukraine is determined to bring as
many as they can like him to justice
we went to one of the villages the 59th
tank regiment may have shelled in
vilhivka the street sign for ukraine
street is still in place but not much
else its houses are all destroyed makola
was there as the russian shells landed
yesterday
i was standing here when the shell hit
everything collapsed and i injured my
head
for three days i couldn't hear blood was
running from my ears
some russian soldiers have already
escaped possible prosecution their
surviving comrades may have fled back to
russia or the east of ukraine but with
painstaking effort evidence is being
gathered against those accused of war
crimes in case they can be brought to
justice dominic waghorn sky news
vilhivka